[Music]
Rick Santorum had a big night last night
he beat Mitt Romney in three states
everyone's wondering what this means for
the Republican Party what turns out that
Andy and I have some strong opinions on
the topic and I thought we'd take him
home to have a quick back-and-forth
about it with our new whip cam debate
you ready Andy yes I am Conan then here
we go Centaurus victories last night
proved there's still a leadership vacuum
among Republicans I disagree conan
romney remains the clear front-runner -
kidding mommy's weak among social
conservatives anyone who says he can win
without them is either ignorant naive or
stupid
[Applause]
what bombas just confused what you can't
help it
yes he can no he can't
yes he can no he can't
I'm wearing a sombrero I've got a kitty
now I've got sunglasses
I've got two kitty
[Applause]
[Music]
when will this show get the respect it
deserves that's my question for you
right now hey we're your kiddies you
just threw them on the ground which a
frettin problem they're napping
what kind of guy throws his kiddies down
they they they're shy yeah besides I'm
longer on camera the more we have to pay
him want to try some hats sucking later
on I gotta call my wife tell her I'll be
late